had this sound and it was a car just
rammed through the crowd and I just
blacked out
[Music]
I hardly had a child who I was always
working and I used to hate it growing up
because I just felt like well when when
am I going to become a child you know
you know play with like other kids
the 10th of February tell me about that
day
man that was a scary thing for me when I
went to the hospital no one knew what to
do I would literally close my eyes I
wouldn't know whether it's here or here
or here or so it was paralyzed at that
point yeah I stayed for three months in
the hospital you know and that depressed
me even more
music helped me so much it brought me
peace this is why I share it it's my way
of healing people the same way it killed
me
my childhood where I come from those
things scare me why do those things
scare you because it's a story it was
for years hard for me to share so what
happened is I
before this conversation starts I've got
a favor to ask from you 74 of people
that watch this podcast frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button and
nine percent of people haven't yet hit
the Bell to turn notifications on the
bigger this platform gets the bigger the
guests get so if you could do me one
favor if you've ever enjoyed this
podcast please hit the Subscribe button
and turn notifications on without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are please keep
this yourself
[Music]
the question I always start this podcast
with because I I studied childhood
psychology for a little while and it was
Illuminating to me how much of our early
years end up defining and shaping us how
who we become so that early context
before 12 years old
what did that look like for you
um when I was born like my parents were
married my mom was super young I was the
first one
um
two other siblings at the time my Mom
married very extremely young probably
like 22-23 already
with three kids divorcing
um we were moved to live with our
grandmother
from the maternal side and she's the one
who raised us
and she used to work in a general
hospital in a sewing room
but I saw her
working extremely hard to go for
everything she wanted
you know like I look back
and try to imagine how much money she
was earning and look at the achievements
like changing her mad house
into a
a big
designed respectable house and she did
this bit by bit by bit and I was a kid I
was there and I saw it
whatever little money should have should
buy the bricks that will wait she buys
sand it weighs to buy gravel it weights
everything
you know slowly so that's what
I learned from her like
to be assertive you wake up you go work
also the strongest thing that I learned
from her is it she had cows and she was
the only woman in the area
you know who had cows you know and she
was single woman and
my job was to every morning called milk
the cows before I go to school
every afternoon after school so I hardly
had a childhood and I came time to play
as a child I was always working
five
o'clock 5 30 from from 11 years old
every single day and
um
that was my environment you know where
I'm like okay whatever you need you just
you have to work there's no other way
and so for the few years
she would make sure I'm up she would
make sure you know I'm on time and
eventually it was my thing she didn't
have to wake me up she didn't have to
tell me when to go she didn't have to if
there was a problem with the cars I knew
what was wrong
if I needed to get medication from the
pharmacy you know I I understood
everything eventually it became my thing
you know
um
that's that's my childhood
where was your father uh my father
remained in Durban and remarried so he
started another family
he worked in a factory
um
they for a company called bacon they
made sweets and chocolates
um
that's where he worked and he just
didn't have
he was a nice guy but he wasn't
presence
you know so on holidays we go see him
you know he would have nothing to say he
wasn't the guy who was like
how was your day
how was school
you know and he advised type of thing
you know he wasn't it was just like the
way he was
you know
um
yet my grandmother was there
she was the man and a woman so she's the
one who basically and I used to hate it
growing up because I just felt like well
when when am I going to become a child
you know and play like other kids and
she was like this
she was super straight she was like
assertive hard-working you know that's
hardly time to do like
all the like the games like other kids
are doing you know so I grew up with
that kind of focus which I hated because
I wanted to be a kid
you know but then
it taught me so much about
just work having a work ethic and
um
that's why I'm able to just pick up
and and leave wherever I can you know
I always reference this conversation I
had with the with the guy that trained
Michael Jordan and Kobe and he told me
that you know these things when we're
young they end up being the consequence
of our of our greatness of our talent
these hard these hardships we have but
they also always come with a cost
so the lack of play the lack of a father
figure the situation of you growing up
in a house where you didn't have
electricity you're milking cows you're
you're you know your food is cooked by
you creating a fire
Etc
what is what is the cost I I can the the
lesson and the value it gave you is so
clear
but what is the cost lots
um
um one of them is just being to myself
you know um
to a point where I have a very small
circle of friends because
I was never a social guy
you know
um so I was
as a kid I always
had to do all the work alone
because your friends will sometimes come
you know but then they realized okay
every day you know so they're not gonna
always come so I was always like a loner
growing up and then
are kind of like
got comfortable with that got
comfortable with trusting my thoughts
and my decisions you know like being
confident in just myself
without needing people
you know and that has like affected a
lot of like personal relationships where
if I just feel a little bit
uneasy
I will just remove myself and it's not
hard for me because I'm like
what I really know is myself
you know but
it's it's a
um something I
want to start working on
because I'm quick to create
a comfortable
space you know I can meet a stranger and
I'm quick to just like
but I I'm much quicker to move as well
you know and it's it's something that
I feel it's not like um
real
you know but it's doable because I'm
always on the move and and and you know
but
um
there are things that I'm like I need to
work on you know
um typically you know I think there's a
bit of a stereotype that black men
aren't the best at emotions and some
some people point at sort of
generational cycles for that
um did you learn how to express your
emotions when you were young
no
it was terrible that it's
[Music]
um
and there was no one like I said my
grandmother was quite tough so
and I look at how I am with my kids
you can
see when you've pushed
a little bit hard you know in
conversation with with someone and you
are able to bring them back you know and
explain like look I'm sorry you know I
was a bit loud there
this is why and you know like
so that they understand all the Dynamics
you know and the older generation
was the one that will whip you you know
and tell you it's gonna hurt me that
more than it hurts you
and that's it you'll get over it because
as a child you have unconditional love
for you
parent you'll eventually get over it and
you're the one coming back making jokes
like nothing happened
you know um
but I didn't have like a good role model
in
in anything
even this
you know I used to like avoid I still do
this uh doing interviews because there's
just again
Society pressure that
if I'm good at making music
am I good in public speaking
so if I play songs nice
am I now role model to your children
more than you
you know but Society will say oh don't
act this way my kids look up to you and
I'm like but I'm just a DJ
who's living his life
and all of a sudden it's like no no but
you can't uh you can't treat like this
because
um it's you
you know so
in in the beginning all I wanted to do
was just play music
like I was that kid even if I'm not
invited at a party I bring my record box
and I wait and I hope they give me a
chance you know that's all I wanted to
do why play music
uh because it's always been my
um Escape
you know in that house where I used to
live and all I did was work and that in
my room
music helped me so much to dream of
these moments
you know like if I listen to
Michael Jackson I imagine where he lives
or in America and that one day I'll go
there
you know
um that's it it really like took me
to all these places so it became my my
friend
you know
um
and I never
had an explanation as to even then
what I would do with it
like when I finished high school I'm
like I'm gonna go to college and study
and my cousins were like are you crazy
then what are you gonna do I didn't know
do you want to be teacher I'm like no
but this is what I want to do as long as
I was surrounded by music that's all I
wanted to do you know uh because it just
it brought me so much peace
happiness
you know and
this is why I share it I share it
because of what it does to me
you know it's my
it's my way of
healing people the same way it healed me
I don't know if I'm making sense make
perfect sense you know I sat here and I
I sat with the biggest comedians in this
country and typically with comedians The
Stereotype is that the comedian is
depressed that so they started cracking
jokes and then one of the comedians came
here and said to me he said you
shouldn't be asking you should never ask
a comedian if they're depressed because
it's usually that they were doing comedy
because one of their parents were
depressed
so comedy became a way for them to see a
smile on their mother's face for the
first time or to see their father smile
for the first time
music and the role it played in your
household
and just in your environment outside of
yourself
um I was wondering as you're saying that
is it also something that created
happiness in others when you were young
that you saw like your your family or
your yeah
um before we moved uh
uh to to my grandmother's place in the
Eastern Cape
the structure of my family back then was
my entire family lived in one house
or not entire but my father and his
brothers
so there was about
four families
and that's where music was like I think
you know one of my uncles my father's
brother
had a like a small
uh we call them ghetto blasters yeah
yeah so he was the music guy he loved
reggae he used to play reggae a lot
that's where I My First Love hurricane
came from like anything as a kid I used
to know different Peter Tosh albums Bob
Marley and the Whalers and all that kind
of music and every now and then then it
will be the pop
that was happening at the time and he
will take it out and all of us will be
out there and we'll dance you know uh
that's that's my my earless childhood
memories with music is that in that big
family when it's hot and it's summer and
we're just all outside and he plays the
music and now we dance anything with
with music you would find me that's why
I never knew what I would do with it you
know uh but I just knew I wherever it is
sometimes they will send me to to the
shops
and
in the township sometimes they'll be
like a big Coca-Cola truck maybe they're
promoting a new flavor and it's parked
in this they play music
they send me to buy bread and I don't
come back
like literally because I'm just there
like I'm just listening to music you
know I don't leave literally and I get
into trouble you know so wherever there
was music that's how I got into it
because my cousin
who's also our neighbor him and his
friend had a mobile sound system so they
were doing weddings like graduation
parties and
and so during the week you'll have the
sound system connected like just small
speaker and you play loud music and I'll
go there
so I'll spend days there and then I
started like
they used to use like cassettes and you
rewind with the pan
so that's how I started you know like
learn and I was curious and
then they will take me to the day
parties then I'll be there opening DJ
you know but I was so curious that
I developed a style of playing you know
uh I was a little bit advanced in
understanding
temples of the songs
and so I wouldn't just randomly play
or play songs that were close together
in Temple
and so all of a sudden the mixes were
like almost Flawless and people were
like
then I became their main DJ you know by
14 15 I was like their main DJ and the
people booking them would tell them
bring that black boy
I was like super dark as a kid
bring him you know and
then I was more cheers then I started
collecting records then I bought 10
tables and I went through my own and
they bring the system I plug more things
you know and then when I finished school
and I moved to another city back to
Durban where there was more
access to things and I I really got into
it so I was studying chairs music
but I was a DJ on the side and sometimes
I would bring 10 tables into the school
Studio
you know
um
it was such a fascinating thing for the
Jazz students because we were there like
learning
chess scales and like the theory of
music and I'm here with my DJing
equipment
you know
at some point actually while I was a
jazz student and a DJ
I did a classical play
like all three same time
you know because me and a friend of mine
uh in the hallway at school
because we were in the choir we were
singing one of the songs we we sang in
high school in the choir and one of the
school lecturers had us and she was
shocked because we were Jazz students
she was like wow you guys you know this
is classical music like you sound so
nice there's a play that's happening at
the playhouse called The Pirates of
Penzance if you were like cool
so we went we auditioned we got the
parts so we would do
chair studies after school we go
practice at the playhouse
and we went to perform we did
um I was opening the show like I was a
tenor you know
um
just anything that had to do with music
so from the from Jazz when I was young
sorry reggae
then I went through different stages
then there was a time where I was like
obsessed with like Fusion
um then gospel music then like classical
music so
and I didn't understand what I was being
prepared for
you know all these years I kept being
exposed to different types and I'm a DJ
so then my taste
varies based on
understanding these different genres
that's why I was able to in 2010
do a show with the 24 piece Orchestra
because 8 000 people yeah in the stadium
so because I was exposed to this music
and I knew where to bridge you know the
gap
the 10th of February
pivotal day in your life yeah
tell me about that day
man 1990. yeah I was talking to to
someone about it because it's a story it
was for years hard for me to share
you know and I'm in a better space now
I'm able to talk about it
um
Street grandmother
we're at home
uh on the 10th
which was like
around eight at night and she was super
strict no one comes out the house that
late we were sitting in the house I
think after dinner we're here like
people singing outside we all come out
everyone comes out to see what's
happening and it's just people singing
there were a group of people about to
pass our house we ran to the crowd with
my cousins you know we were not allowed
to but this was nice so it wasn't a big
thing even I mean for her
but my cousin my cousins went back I
didn't
why music
so I followed the crowd and the reason
this was happening is because on the
11th of February
Nelson Mandela was officially coming out
of jail after 27 years so there was like
tribulations around the entire country
this was happening in all the major
cities where people were like we're
going to stay up all night until the
morning
you know uh of his release
so this card was going to a stadium
which is close to my house
um
that's where the
the camping was going to be the singing
until the morning in the stadium so they
went on the streets basically Gathering
more crowds and we were now close to the
stadium
and just out of nowhere we just had this
sound
um and it was a car just came out of
nowhere lights off
rammed through the crowd
so I was I was not in the front but I
was
maybe like 20 percent in
and I split out
um and people were screaming and when I
woke up
um there was fire you know people were
angry so basically this driver
Switched Off the Lights
to literally just kill people with this
car
and
um so they bent the car before they bent
the guy too
and um they burnt the guy yeah
they pulled him out of the car and
killed him yeah
literally and he stayed there for hours
actually without anyone coming for him
because I remember
this happened around four in the morning
went to a hospital around
30 minutes later their cars took us to
hospital I came back from the hospital
around seven eight he was still there
that I cannot even cover it his car he
was still lying there on the ground
that cost his life and someone else's
life who was also in the crowd
um so by that time I mean it's seven in
the morning I'm back from hospital
the announcement happens Nelson Mandela
is finally out of jail we're watching
this from TV I'm sitting on the couch
you know it's just
chaos in the country people are so happy
this man is finally out
and
um
I was on the couch in pain you know uh
after the accident
and I think what really happened to me I
don't think the car reached to me I
don't think the car
touched me
I think the force of the people that
were in front because of the impacts
they pushed so hard so what happened is
I dislocated my shoulder
but severely
I had no prosies no cards it just came
off
meaning
um
my nerves that connect the arm to the
body
were snatched
and being in a small town
when I went to the hospital no one knew
what to do
so I'm there I'm holding my arm like
they don't know if it's broken they
don't know
what to do with it you know so they just
gave me a sling and paint tablets and I
went back home
but the pain was couldn't stop and then
um
the following day then I went to Durban
which is the biggest city to go to like
a bigger Hospital
where I stayed for three months in the
hospital you know and even that they
didn't know what to do one morning they
were like okay uh we figured it out they
put a cast
so I'd have a car for like two weeks
but the damage was here but I was a kid
as well so
I didn't understand you know
um
so the danger is called racial plexus
which is the damage of of nerves and
there's nothing you can do to fix
damaged nerves they can only fix
themselves so over time
um so they try different things
at some point I remember I was being
taken to like a specialist
to see if there was life on my arm
so
um because they were thinking of
amputating my arm
so they put this device that had
electricity
to see if it's gonna I'm gonna feel it
and there was this like probably like
five percent of life
and he was like no we don't have to do
it over time the nails would grow back
and that's what has happened you know
and as a kid I'm not 14 it was
life-changing you know
um the things I wouldn't I wasn't able
to do uh
um activities there was just things I
couldn't I was in a music class
you know
um
so I couldn't participate when on the
piano
uh like lessons and we used to play
recorders and so I went through a phase
where
it really affected me
and
just over time I was like actually
I have a life to live
when you say you went through a phase
where it really affected you what does
that mean like why me I mean I mean when
when you
are born fine all of a sudden and kids
can be mean so the name calling comes
and you know because also I thought he
was gonna pass and I would as a kid even
have dreams you know I wake up I'm like
oh I had a dream last night my hand was
working and I was doing this and you
know and so to me it was like maybe next
week and maybe next month you know I'm
gonna be fine again and
so I went through a lot of sites you
know and and eventually acceptance like
okay
this is what it is you know um
I have to leave I have to move on
and I kind of like stop thinking about
it
and just focused on
what's next
how do I learn to
um tie my shoes
you know
um
or just wake up and do everything
without calling for help
that was the most important thing for me
because I didn't want to feel sorry for
myself because the most important thing
where
I was like I need to learn how to not to
call anyone for anything
zero like then
that was a big thing for me
what's the what condition is your left
your left arm in now as we sit here
um it is changed probably like 40
movement and
um
we put it this way when it happened
I would literally close my eyes and I
would know where it was
okay
so it was paralyzed at that point yeah
the whole um I wouldn't know whether
it's here or here or here or you know
um so over time I've started feeling
things I can differentiate between hot
water and cold water
um
and every now and then because that's
another thing I should do physiotherapy
a lot
another kid and I used after school I go
and I train and that and that depressed
me even more because I was waiting for
results
you know and I thought I'm training for
muscle that wasn't coming so I couldn't
see anything
and when I stopped I stopped everything
I stopped thinking about it I stopped
waiting for it to be better acceptance
yeah so
uh even now it's like
if I woke up and it was fine
do I even need it that's where I met
like
doesn't really matter
you know I think my life has turned out
though exactly how it's supposed to
this happened to you when you were 14
but you didn't share it with the world
until 2017 yeah in a Facebook post yeah
because as an artist I just felt like
I did not want to be seen as that guy
um
who
has a disability you know uh where it's
like oh you know like um
I didn't want a pity party you know I
just wanted to be
understood and had like everyone else
you know so
my first album came out in 2005.
that's it I just worked on music
released it I used to TJ the way I do
and through this thing Scott plays with
his hand in his pocket
as with that you know like it looks cool
about what's you know and I thought you
were just the coolest [ __ ] ever
yeah people were like because the hand
thing in the pocket happened when I was
a kid and because I used to have this
laying and even when I run with other
kids and I used to have to hold this
hand because it was just moving
everywhere and one day I was like I just
put it in the pocket
and I was like damn this is more
functional than having a sling and I
never stopped you know and so it wasn't
even a thing like that was like so deep
it just happened when I was young and I
was like actually I feel comfortable
like this and over time it became
you know I think because also being um
the introvert that I am it helps me in
not explaining myself because everyone
even now there's a
there's things that like that um
supports you can buy them from Pharmacy
I have them so when I'm home I use that
and when I have people at my house I use
it or when I swim even people who know
me are like are you okay what happened
you know these were things I was
avoiding to be having to explain myself
all the time like you know
um I was like I sit and I look normal
like everyone else and there's people
promise you in my life today
who don't know
and
it's fine
did it make you work harder or have to
work harder to get to where you are
definitely
definitely
especially as a DJ
you know because I just felt like this
thing was trying to rob me off
this one thing that I really really love
and I will not allow it
you know uh so it made me in that sense
not even in a sense of who's gonna
employ me I'm [ __ ] my life is a mess
it was like if there's one thing I'm not
going to lose
his music
you know I won't stop I have to be a DJ
I have to I have two and I'm from the
cassette era to the final I mean how do
you take a vinyl out of it
final package with one hand
and this used to stress me and when I
look at it I'm like
how will I become a professional DJ
you know and it takes me not it took me
not thinking
I just like did it you know like I'm
like this is one thing I want to do
so
I just went all the way I I go to school
I remember there was a time where I'll
spend at least two hours every day DJing
before I didn't play for a club or every
day two hours of my time
because I and I used to say this like I
just want to be ready
like one day when someone says you're a
DJ I must boldly say yeah
I am you know and
I look now and I play it sometimes I'm
like
man you're good
like
I look uh I'm like wow
you know because I developed the style
you know
um
of playing that
is my own based on understanding myself
and what I can do you know
um
I have a friend sienda who grew up with
is also a DJ and
when I started like back in the day like
really when I was spending time
practicing I used to be really crazy and
he says this all the time that they
don't even know how crazy you are
because now I don't do
I don't do anything I just play less is
more you know I'm more experienced now
but my understanding of it is like on on
a different level
you know but I'm at a space where I'm
like I don't have to to
you know that's where I'm at I think I
have to yeah I don't have to because
I've been there it's like learning
the basic course and you go
to an advanced course
you know uh go Advanced driving
doesn't mean you're gonna come on the
road and drive like you were on the
advanced driving school you know it's
just understanding and knowing but when
I look at this thing
it's part of me the deck yeah quick word
from one of my sponsors
um super excited to announce that our
new sponsor for the podcast is Intel a
brand that pretty much every single
person listening to this is a user of
but in some cases you might not even
know for those that don't know Intel is
a technological Powerhouse who have been
driving Technology Innovation and
transformation for more than 50 years we
all know that technology has never been
more important than it is today and
Intel is truly shaping the future of our
industry from keeping us connected
through 5G which we use in all of our
lives every single day to modernizing
computers to transforming businesses
through data and analytics the list goes
on and on and on I've been particularly
excited to announce the sponsorship
because we've been using Intel's
technology throughout this building and
on this podcast for some time now and it
makes our lives so much easier in so
many ways especially as it relates to
producing this show for you so head over
to intel.co.uk and you can find out why
they've become an essential piece of
technology in my day-to-day routine let
me know what you
my girlfriend came upstairs yesterday
when I was having a shower and she said
to me that she tried the heel protein
shake which lives on my fridge over
there and she said it's amazing low
calories you get your 20 odd grams of
protein you get your 26 vitamins and
minerals and it's nutritionally complete
in the protein space there's lots of
things but it's hard to find something
that is nice especially when consumed
just with water and that is
nutritionally complete and that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein if
you haven't tried the Keel protein
product do give it a try The Salted
Caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one when
you or else I think you were you were in
your early twenties they asked you you
know I think you just was that around
the time you've done the Red Bull
um
your early 20s they asked you in an
interview where you were going to be in
two years
oh man do you remember I was a scary
thing for me
um
I remember that I'll never forget it you
know I don't think that was me talking
you know I just
um
it was
it was Black Coffee
someone I wasn't yet you know um
because I I was never that guy you know
I didn't I didn't have
I don't want to insult my schools and
say I didn't have the right education
but you know I look at my kids schools
where they go to they learn public
speaking they know how to present
themselves and they know how to get
across a point a point across they know
how to speak
and
I'm not from there everything that I
kind of like have I had to figure it out
myself
you know and so during an interview then
being asked this question and at the
worst time of my life then
and give and give that answer because
the question was where do you see
yourself and I said
they said in two years and I said in
five years just gave myself time I said
in five years I'm going to be one of the
most important producers
I don't know if I said off the continent
or the country
you know which actually I'm proud of
that because it could have been worse
you know I could have said I want to be
number one I want to be the baddest
[ __ ] I would I would have said
something crazy like Pampers you know my
answer was still like very modest and
but I was clear about
what I wanted you know uh but after
saying it I freaked out because then I
realized I need to own this I need to
own it and I need to
then start working towards it you know
and
yeah and then two years later which was
the question
I released my album and I won my first
award for best album
you know which was low-key
then I was the best producer in the
genre in the country you know uh
but I think
I don't know like
if it's the Star Wars that drive me or
uh just success itself
because there's the narrative that oh
he's probably
I can't get a Grammy like he wants
something more he wants more he wants
more and I don't think I look at things
like that I think
I just know that
um I can do more than in a world I can
do more than an achievement I can do
more than
you know I'm capable
that's it that's what I'm I'm I'm I'm
fighting for
you know uh and it's a little boy in me
who was milking cows who had no friends
who was like
I can especially coming from where I
come from
and that's it it's never really about
I'm the smartest one and I'm I'm gonna
be the best one
I'm the most gifted one it's just like
I started with nothing I'm from like
nowhere really like so
and I had nothing to lose
you know so I threw myself in and I just
want to keep going
when you look back at the you know you
said that in your early 20s two years
later your album wins um wins that
amazing award your career continues to
go to the moon when you look back in
hindsight with wisdom and say ah because
I think it's always in hindsight you go
that's why I got here you've talked
about the obsessiveness yeah I get that
I get the drive the hunger but as it
relates to the creativity
and the the craftsmanship and all the
other things why you and why not some
other young you know South African DJ
from
the Eastern Cape uh I think
that's what I think
it's just being intentional about
what you want
um
the people I work with
from the beginning
so it's always just like the goal is
similar we we don't try to
I don't think we Chase number one
you know we just we we we just want
quality
we strive for Quality we understand the
less is more
Concepts
um
I've never and I've treated this once in
my country as well I've never
gone for like a one song of the year
those things scare me
I just want to release music that
has the kind of substance that I love
what do these things scare you
because I just feel like then you have
to keep chasing the number one so if I
am this year then I must be next year
otherwise then there's a deep
that's going to come with that if I'm
not so
we do what we're comfortable with
because what we're comfortable with we
can do it again
you know and improve it and improve it
so the goal is always the same like not
to try and
go mainstream
be comfortable
you know you can wake me up
tomorrow and be like can you make a song
like drive I'll be like
I can probably better
than oh I can never make that song again
because wow you know it's in my space
you know everything is in my sound Bank
everything I work with is always around
you know and also I think now I'm
clearer as
to who I am as an artist you know I'm
more of um
I'll say
65 DJ
that's where all my energy is
and then 35
um
uh producer
having sat here with with Diplo and
other
um artists Jessie J yeah um the boys
from One Direction Liam Payne
what I had over and over again from them
is that with success in music there
becomes more authority figures record
labels Etc telling you how you should
sound and telling you that if you sound
like this then you'll get a number one
and it'll be mainstream etc etc how
important over the course of your career
as you look back has it been to try and
stay true to yourself despite the
temptation to fit
someone's
that's an easy part for us you know
because
first of all
what am I looking for like what I just
explained to you now is being a More DJ
than a producer
so DJing pays our bills that's our Core
Business
therefore
that's where we're going to be strongest
and releasing music is
the second part of the business
so it being the second best part of the
business means
it's not the main thing and so there's
no pressure in then
following all the trends that come and
and
I've been quite fortunate
in my career from the beginning when I
released my first album
I released it
with the licensing bill meaning I did it
on my own and I submitted you know to a
level so no one could say
we don't like number five take out
number seven
don't you want to fix number two you
know it was a darling package album
and that's been the nature of my
production career
where
the last album that I did was the first
album with the a label in the US where
there was that
um
Authority
you know and it would mostly come as
we're not sure about this one but what I
did
I separated my African releases
from the global releases
therefore when they're like we're not
sure I'm like it's okay I'll release it
in Africa
where I know it will make more sense and
also it fits the sound that I'm doing
that I wanted to you know so I remember
when I was something I released
was a song called your eyes with the
South African artist called Chicano
brilliant song and they were like
um
released it and immediately after it
came out they changed their minds
they're like okay maybe not we'll also
release the song
you know because we were not following
what they want you know and we were cool
with it you know
um then after I released an EP called
music is King which was purely purely
for
like
the African markets because even now I
don't have a label
so I don't have to
have these conversations about what song
I want to do and how does it sound
but still when I do
my team knows I want to separate the two
Africa must be on its own because one
day I may wake up and be like I've
always been a fan of salificator I want
to do a song instead of cater
and when you do a song with Salif keita
being a Grammy winning artist
if you put that song on an album that
album might not be nominated
on the
dance electronic album
because the language is foreign they
will take that album and shelve it with
the world music
that means you're competing against your
African
brothers and sisters which is and I
really hate
so my point is I don't separate the two
if I want to do a single
with an African artist I can do that
before not do like a Grammy quality kind
of work
I can still do it but I'm fortunate not
to have those kind of Gatekeepers and
authorities are telling me now
and I can understand with the Deep loss
in them you know they are their
structures are different but we we're
fortunate to we we've structured out
things well
how many shows so you said 60 DJing how
many shows
do you do in a busy year
I don't know man
um Ibiza
this summer I think I did 21. Justin
Bieber is alone on Saturdays at high
right yeah yeah I was there for two of
them so yeah just Saturdays alone
and so I've been there since May so
meaning
every
uh weekend
Thursday Friday I'm somewhere else
Sunday I'm somewhere else every weekend
every weekend
so Thursday Friday Saturday and Sunday
and Sunday yeah sometimes you're gonna
be flying around that's what we do yeah
so before I am somewhere else after high
I'm somewhere else like I had a show
here on a Sunday yesterday
tomorrow
you know so sometimes it's Tuesday
sometimes it's Wednesdays but every
summer it's like
for every Saturday there's a Thursday
into Friday and a Sunday sometimes how
many shows is that in a year though if
you were to add an opposite because I
read that it was more than 150 sometimes
no it is yeah definitely
that's a lot of shows I think I you know
I had I did my little tour of this
podcast and we did nine and I was
[ __ ] knackered
in two months and I was like you have to
wait another year before I do that
because of the adrenaline and all the
feelings and the emotion and the
performance and it's late and whatever
else how
no I think at this point I mean
um
this is what we do
you know if you look at the
you made a reference about Michael
Jordan and Kobe can you imagine like the
hours they spent like to get to that
level you know
um it becomes second nature you know the
first thing that comes to mind is that
little boy milking cows
like
this is a blessing
so nine shows
you must have made good money for you to
complain
I don't think we made any money
you're like I'm done I'm retiring
no but I do Wonder because you know I
hear about the the kid that was milking
the cows with no electricity back in
back in South Africa and
you know it's sometimes my fear is that
that kid is going to when that kid
becomes an adult he will make decisions
which will compromise other needs
because he's so generative to survive
definitely at some point as you said
before I think we start recording you've
got to step out of survival at some
point and go know that's why therapy is
such an important thing you know uh
for us I mean I I I've had so many
different conversations with South
African artists
some have had conflict with and you know
when we meet and try to solve the
conflict I'm like let me tell you what's
going to help all of us it's therapy
because how do I go
um from being that boy
you know living in the same community
where like no one even looked at me
you know and you fast forward I'm coming
back to that same Community like in a
Lamborghini and everyone wants a picture
and it's a
it's a mind [ __ ]
just to me you know so you need to
really work on yourself when you cross
that line where it's like
someone you looked up to
uh as a kid you thought this guy is so
successful and you realize that actually
you are the successful one
so how is the shift then even in
respecting that person
you know because then one was like I'm
the king now
you know then another is like you're
still the king you did this before me
I'm paying so much respects to you so
it's it's a very thin line
between
um
seeing yourself as a king over everyone
else or knowing you are and still
respecting everyone else and that's the
balance for me and it took me such a
long time and I'm still battling and I'm
working on it and I'm a little bit
better now in understanding the
difference between Nazi and black coffee
what is the difference between nutty and
black coffee the little boy in yourself
as a DJ um black coffee has all the
Privileges
right it's like
it's a joke in my house and sometimes
when uh I want to go eat in a restaurant
and I I think late I'm like damn I need
to go and you know and I have I tell my
sister please book and then she's like
oh well not now it used to happen like
that she's like oh it's fully booked and
then I'm like no but just tell them
who's calling and then she's like oh
yeah yeah table for two sorted you know
those are the perks of
those are black coffee packs where it's
like
if not to cold the restaurant is full
is if black coffee cold
there's a seed for you there's a table
for you so
not just a kid that grew up
going through a magazine and seeing
model girls
you know like
thinking wow if one day I can have a
girlfriend like this
right that's nutty and but nothing ever
had access to that and never would given
where he comes from
but black coffee
has
access to that so
then sometimes not he uses Black Coffee
you know
to
to
satisfy Natty where it's like
instead of saying hi I'm naughty
it's oh you black coffee and I'm like
hmm yeah you understand so it's a it's
two different things to a point where
even where I live now
it's crazy but that's how it is where
I first bought myself a house this is
with my developed four stories that's
not even final I moved out of the house
so I'm like life is going to be so dope
you know now that I'm a single guy and
I live in this apartment and in between
tours I go back and like wow
and then toys over I'm back home I'm
sitting I'm like
this is my life
you know like I just the house I left I
just finished building now I live in an
apartment like a student
let me look for a house for myself then
I look for a house and I found it so I
have the house but now I'm like it's a
big house
very slowly because I'm from family I
live alone so I'm like Mom don't you
want to move and come stay with me which
I think it's a noble thing you know
because my mom had like a heart problem
so she moves and then uh I have the
warmth of the family right it's nice and
I'm like
but is this my life
I live with my mother
so means
I can't bring my friends here like kind
of have a little party because my mom is
in the other room then it bothers me so
much and I think I remember having a
conversation with my friend I'm like man
I love it but at the same time I even
told her you know I'm like
I just feel like
this can't be it
you know I'm like I'm about to finalize
my divorce and I live with my mother
you know and the most incredible thing
happened I got a phone call
just that week when it was stressing me
so much I got a phone call it's a number
I don't know I'm like yo and then this
guy is like uh my name is Michael I'm
your neighbor and we have this long
conversation on the phone and then it's
like by the way
I'm selling my house
and I'm going away we're moving to
another country and
just letting you know as a neighbor
because it was like um
a solution
so I bought the neighbor's house
and in my crazy head the neighbor's
house that's where my mom and children
are going to stay that's a naughty house
right so that's where you're gonna find
me on the floor on the grass playing
with my children the next door that's
the black coffee house I want to come to
the Black Coffee House
you know but the thing is about the
black coffee house which is what before
we started recording you asking me
what's on my mind and I was telling you
Legacy Legacy Legacy
I want to build black coffee house as a
like a black coffee house I would be
like a future black coffee house okay
not a current black coffee house no
current but it will be a future
this is where he used to live ah okay
you know so I'm I'm very much
intentional about the things I collect
the art on the wall like everything that
I do I'm doing to create value in the
house you know to have Steve come to
this house and we take a picture by the
pool and it goes to the wall of fame oh
nice you know so tell me when you know
like create this value out of it you
know any kind of friends that you know
like a known in the world that come to
visit we create all the memorabilia if
even the suit I want the Grammys you
know frame it and you know I've kept it
and the shoes and you know like that's
their whole idea to kind of like build
um like a legacy project for my kids who
are living next door you know in a
normal
setting where
uh they're not exposed to or
um
their lives are normal
you know you know like having a day with
the kids in the pool and then Drake's
walk Drake is walking in you know like
Steve yeah you know what I mean so
that's the difference between the
between black coffee and Nazi I'm just
like taking it that far where I'm
understanding that their different
Dynamics
when you told me the story of going from
a divorce in a house to an apartment
Penthouse to a house with your mother to
let anything next door back in on your
own it sounded to me like someone that
was struggling to try and have the best
of both worlds continually yeah because
in your own words you were told that the
best life was to be married yeah tried
that yeah discovered that for you it
wasn't so you went back to the penthouse
yeah which is where yeah which is like
damn Bachelor single we're about to yeah
and then you're in the penthouse you go
[ __ ] I need to be back in that house
environment yeah and then you get the
mother back in and the Mum comes in and
you go
actually no
um the day my divorce is signed how do I
celebrate
you know it can be in front of my mother
you know so you're right uh but remember
it's it's all
the search
that's what it is searching for
happiness
and
in the end I don't think
we're gonna be able to find and Define
it
what is your happiness it's gonna be
um
it's not a destination
you know it's going to be like um
a series of different things you know
where boxes are ticked you know if all
those boxes are ticked though
are you then happy you can't take them
all
because because life is is so long and
we keep discovering things to take
you know and they all have different
meanings you know uh which is where
there's this small boy's journey and
you know because if it was a small boy's
boxes to tick by now it will be done
you you understand so there's boxes of
an adult like you're saying you live
here and then you extend and then you
know upstairs you keep and then you're
gonna be like actually I need to buy
another building that's how it is but
but all these things they we're never
going to stop
I often think that I was thinking there
about advice and you know a lot of that
advice tends to come from our parents
but um
I often think that
when we've come from a place of hardship
and I just think generally I think
there's a lot in my own life
um there's words that I wish I
I said or could say now to my
parents
there's words that I wish I could say to
my um my mother my father you spoke so
lovingly at the beginning of this
conversation about the role that your
mother played in your life
is your mother still with us yes cheers
yeah I spoke to her on my way here
she is out
are there any words that you found
difficult to say to her
um not anymore you know I love you as
one of them
uh because
she it was never um
part of
our family
as like an African family to have that
kind of form than these kind of
conversations
you know
um
even even our hugs are still a little
bit awkward but they still hugs because
it's never been their generation didn't
do that
you know uh they would show you and
you'd know your parents love you
the in the best way they they will do it
you know and being a parent
I am so much aware
of
how I want to teach my kids to be able
to say it and
like randomly hug them because I never
you know had that growing up and then in
the end we are the ones who come back
and teach our parents you know no matter
how awkward it gets
you know
teach them to say and they then they
learn even though it's like it's not
something they know
yeah we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest they write
it in the book they don't know who
they're writing it for
the question that was written for you
and it's funny oh oh oh oh yeah they've
written a question for you but they
didn't know who they're writing which is
the most amazing thing ever when you
hear this question
what is your favorite sound
laughter
why because
people laugh when they are happy
and going back to what I said in the
beginning
I think personally that's what we're
searching for
as it's a human race which is looking
for happiness
thank you thank you for being so
generous with your time thank you for
giving me some of the best nights of my
life thank you for
um coming here inspiring me thank you
for your your vulnerability which I know
will help so many people and thank you
just for being a creative inspiration
for me as I said I'm I'm trying to DJ at
the moment I've got my decks upstairs so
um I've read that you're looking for you
know young South African Talent so
it's been a pleasure thank you
appreciate appreciate the invitation it
was really I was nervous about coming
here right now like
you know opening up and but it worked
out well thank you
quick one we have a brand new sponsor on
this podcast which I'm very excited to
tell you about they're a brand called
Blue Jeans by Verizon and they are a
video conferencing and collaboration
tool that has changed the game for our
team so I'm so glad to be working with
them because as you know one of the most
important things for me is when we have
a sponsor it is part of my world it is
part of my life it is part of my
companies as someone who's on calls
pretty much 80 of the day building where
businesses and speaking to my teams all
over the world it's the guaranteed
security that differentiates blue jeans
from all of the other options that are
out there in terms of video conferencing
their Enterprise grade security means
you can protect your organization from
malicious attacks and establish real
trust with everyone that joins your
meeting and that is something there are
so many things that make sense and make
blue jeans
um a better option than the sort of
competitors out there and I'll be
talking about all of those aspects those
features and the reasons why I use blue
jeans in the coming episodes if you want
to check it out you can head to
www.blueans.com to learn more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]